- [Instructor] In a previous video,
we introduced ourselves to the
idea of bonds between atoms,
and we talked about the types of bonds,
ionic, covalent
and metallic.
In this video we're going
to dig a little bit deeper
and talk about the types of bonds
that are likely to be formed
between different elements.
And to understand that,
I'm going to introduce
a broad classification of the elements,
and in general, we're just
going to think about things
as metals and as nonmetals.
So before I even point out on
the periodic table of elements
what are the metals and
what are the nonmetals
and maybe what are the
ones that are in between,
what are the properties of metals?
Well, generally speaking,
they conduct electricity.
Conduct electricity.
They tend to be malleable,
which is just a fancy way
of saying that you can
bend them without breaking.
And generally speaking, and
there's exceptions to this,
they are solid at room temperature.
So I'll say solid at room temperature.
Now what do you think the properties
of nonmetals are going to be?
Well generally speaking,
they're going to be the opposite of this.
Nonmetals, generally speaking,
at room temperature are often not solid,
they're often times gasses.
They are not going to
conduct electricity well.
Now when you look at a
periodic table of elements,
how do you divide the
metals from the nonmetals?
Well that's what this
little scratchy yellow line
I'm drawing is trying to indicate.
So everything above and to
the right of this yellow line
is a nonmetal and if you
look at the color code
from the folks who made this
periodic table of elements,
everything in this yellow
color that we have here,
so hydrogen and carbon and nitrogen
and oxygen and fluorine,
chlorine, I could keep going,
these are all nonmetals.
And it is the case that generally speaking
at room temperature, they
will be in a gas form
and they will not
conduct electricity well.
These things in blue we've
talked about in other videos,
these are the noble gasses.
So these are also nonmetals.
The people who made this
periodic table of elements
put them in their own color
'cause then you could view
them as a subclass of nonmetals
and they tend to be very inert,
they don't interact with other things.
They don't tend to form
any of these bonds.
Now everything else, you can consider
in some form to be a metal
and the reason why this
periodic table of elements
has different colors is that
there's subclassifications
of the metals
but generally speaking,
all of these things
that you see right over here
below this scratchy yellow line
have the properties, generally speaking,
of conducting electricity,
being malleable,
being solid at room temperature.
And these things that straddle
this yellow line right over here,
these things that are in this kind
of bluish-green kind of color,
these are sometimes viewed as metalloids
because they have some
properties of metals
and some properties of nonmetals.
But generally speaking,
if you know whether
the things reacting are
metals or nonmetals,
you can oftentimes
predict what type of bond
is going to form.
So for example, if I have
a bond between a metal,
a metal and a nonmetal, and a nonmetal,
what type of bond do you
think is going to form?
Well when you bond between a net metal
and a nonmetal, and we
saw an example of that
in that first video on bonding,
say a metal like sodium, and
then a nonmetal like chlorine,
we saw that that chlorine
will swipe an electron,
the sodium might lose one,
then the chlorine atom
becomes a chloride anion,
and then the sodium atom
becomes a sodium cation
and then they become
attracted to each other
and then you form an ionic bond.
So this tends to form ionic bonds.
Now what if you were to have
a nonmetal with a nonmetal?
Nonmetal times two,
so two nonmetals bind,
bound, I'm having trouble saying it,
two nonmetals bonding to each other.
What do you think is going to happen?
Well we saw as an example
in that first video
where we say well what happens
if oxygen bonds to oxygen?
Well we saw that was a covalent bond
and that is generally the case
when you have two nonmetals
form bonds, it is covalent.
And then last but not least,
and this might be the most
obvious one of them all,
what do you think happens when you have
two metals forming a bond?
Well you can imagine that
will be a metallic bond
where they contribute
electrons to this kind
of sea of electrons and
that's what makes them
conduct electricity so well and malleable.
So I'll leave you there.
There are exceptions to
everything I just talked about
but generally speaking,
these notions will serve you well,
especially in an
introductory chemistry class.